[Music]
sir what's your name
nobody whoa all right and what do you uh
what brings you to the mother of all
patriot rallies today
well i came to educate the trump
cheerleaders that donald trump is not a
true patriot
as he said he is okay that's fair um now
what what is it specifically that you
have against trump and his policies
well for soldiers trump's policies will
affect people like myself but primary
poor white people who support him
okay that's fair um are traps gay
traps what's that uh like
are they guys is it gay to be sexual
you don't want to hear my kind about
that all right fair enough um
is isis a reliable ally to fight against
degeneracy
i'm here i'm not here to answer your
your adi questions i'm here to
to emphasize how trump is not a true
patriot
now very soon donald trump has get very
soon donald trump will give russia
access to our national security and our
defense vladimir putin
vladimir putin has is
donald trump is is having
donald trump is some is close with
vladimir putin so he can expand trump
enterprise trump hotels resorts in
russia that's not
russia has been has our enemy for years
now all of a sudden
this so-called we thought the so-called
this
so-called american president is helping
it's helping our enemy
um but didn't cnn admit that that was a
big and i quote nothing burger
well the two the true news is cnn and
c-span
fox news is the fake news and so is new
york post
and washington times and is that the
same cnn that's been caught fabricating
stories probably
at least a dozen times in the last year
so on hand you fabricate a story against
the the young the young man who who is a
democratic lobbyist
okay but uh but i'm i'm talking see but
i'm talking about like you know uh
them reporting that he was called a
traitor i well i know but cnn reported
that trump liked russian hookers to pee
on him
and uh they believed stories that 4chan
planted in the news
and uh they've been shown staging things
at hurricane events and uh trying to
fake rescues for their news
so isn't all is it all news fake news i
do know for a fact
that fox news fabricated they have
history of fabricating
and make and making black black black
victims who was killed by
who was killed by racist white cops
as thugs and suspects
and as and cnn's never done that see
it's been
csn tell the truth all right now if you
want to go further
the most informative press is the
economist a british
a british economic and political
magazine
watching hispanic in local inaugural
space newspaper
and your new york times in your usa
today
all right i got two more questions for
you i don't know are you familiar with
the juggalo rally that's going on as
well
uh the juggalos they're a fan of a music
group called insane clown posse
the fbi recently uh designated them as a
gang organization
uh is that something that you uh think
is fair
anybody who's against anybody who who's
who
who's against the the fastest is a
terrorist or
all right one more question for you who
was the worst president in american
history and why was it barack obama
president obama is the best person we
have in this country
he did more he did more for for for
for blacks whites hispanics
and the homosexuals that now know about
your account about the homosexuals
now again do you know that donald trump
had weighed a gay rights flag
at one of his campaign rallies last year
and now and now he
now he's telling now he passed he passed
a ban he's been
transgender in the u.s military
yeah but that was literally like eight
people
the us generals do not want sexuals
the us generals i'm not trying i'm not
trying to say i'm again
i'm i'm not trying to say i'm a i'm a
gay i'm a gay rights advocate but
what trump did to them is wrong he has
no right to
he has no right to decide who's who's to
join who's not joined the military
considering
he never joined the military he dodged
the military in vietnam
is there anything you'd like to promote
a platform twitter account anything like
that
all i want to say you do always say to
your to your audience
is that open up your eyes and get trump
stick out your ass
i want to give you a gift for uh for for
interviewing with us today we are giving
out in honor of the juggalo march
we have faygo soda fresh from north
carolina by the case
uh we want to give this to you if you'd
like to if it's not it's maybe cane
sugar what's up i cannot drink any
anything that has high for this corn
syrup looks like we're
not going to be giving them any faygo
then because this is very cheap crappy
corn syrupy
uh stuff so sorry about that we would
have hooked you up
but uh thank you so much your name again
and
i hope uh to all you dumbass and support
trump
you need to wake up before it's too late
do not complain and trump cut your cut
trump cut your health care do not
complain that you can't you cannot find
a job
once 24 million of hispanics thank you
so much for coming out today we
appreciate it
you